The following episode of How We Made Your Mother was recorded live on Instagram on February 12th, 2026.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》的下一集于 2026 年 2 月 12 日在 Instagram 上现场录制。
Hey everyone, welcome.
大家好，欢迎光临。
What's today?
今天是什么日子？
Thursday?
周四？
Something like that?
类似的事情？
Yeah, Thursday.
是的，星期四。
We switched these to noon so we could, our friends from different parts of the world could join us, so welcome.
我们把时间改到中午，这样来自世界各地的朋友就可以加入我们，非常欢迎。
Let us know where you're viewing from.
让我们知道您从哪里观看。
We love to hear to get a kind of geographic slate of where people are chiming in from.
我们喜欢听到人们从哪里发表意见的地理信息。
Craig and I cannot see your questions and requests for shout out for different countries shout outs but Alec is sifting through them for us and he's gonna bring your questions to us so yeah so Craig co-created how I met your mother he's my dear friend we I start on that show as Ted Mosby we have been working through all the episodes on a podcast a rewatch podcast called How We Made Your Mother we are done In recording season two, we have two seasons, but season two is still rolling out wherever you get your podcasts.
克雷格和我看不到你的问题和对不同国家大声喊出的要求，但亚历克正在为我们筛选这些问题，他会把你的问题带给我们，所以是的，克雷格共同创造了我如何遇见你母亲的方式，他是我亲爱的朋友，我们以特德·莫斯比的身份开始那个节目，我们一直在播客上重看播客，名为《我们如何创造了你的母亲》，我们已经完成了在录制第二季时，我们有两季，但第二季是无论您在哪里获得播客，仍然会推出。
If you haven't yet joined us, please listen, spread the word.
如果您还没有加入我们，请倾听并传播这个信息。
We love this show.
我们喜欢这个节目。
We love rewatching this show and talking about every episode.
我们喜欢重看这个节目并谈论每一集。
Craig, what else should we add?
克雷格，我们还应该补充什么？
Yeah, we're up to Lucky Penny.
是的，我们就看幸运便士了。
I think that's this week's episode.
我想这就是本周的剧集。
So that's like in the teens of season two, so we're more than halfway through season two.
就像第二季十几岁的时候一样，所以我们第二季已经过半了。
our favorite part by far of the whole thing other than getting to hang out with each other and with Alec, our producer Alec Lev and everybody on the team is hearing from you guys.
到目前为止，我们最喜欢的部分除了彼此和亚历克、我们的制作人亚历克·列夫以及团队中的每个人一起出去玩之外，都收到了你们的来信。
And the reason we're doing these IG lives is because it's just another way to connect with the fans and get the word out.
我们进行这些 IG 直播的原因是因为它只是与粉丝联系并传播信息的另一种方式。
These will eventually become bonus episodes.
这些最终将成为奖励剧集。
So if we do take your question today, that will be an episode of the podcast that will roll out at some point in a month or two or however Alec will advise, I'm not sure how long, but this will be on our podcast feed.
因此，如果我们今天确实回答您的问题，那将是播客的一集，将在一两个月内的某个时候推出，或者亚历克会建议的，我不确定要持续多久，但这将出现在我们的播客提要中。
So please send us your questions and your thoughts and we'll make a podcast episode lab style.
因此，请将您的问题和想法发送给我们，我们将制作实验室风格的播客剧集。
I just noticed that I have baby drool on my sweatshirt.
我刚刚注意到我的运动衫上有婴儿的口水。
But I also want to say that it would be hard for me to find anything to wear that didn't have some configuration working.
但我也想说，我很难找到任何没有某些配置工作的衣服。
You were in that zone.
你就在那个区域。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
That lasts for a while.
这会持续一段时间。
Because it's a baby drool that becomes like food that has thrown at you.
因为这是婴儿的口水，它变得像扔给你的食物一样。
And you got about two or three of that.
你得到了大约两到三个。
You know who's really looking forward to my son eating food?
你知道谁真正期待我儿子吃东西吗？
Nelson the dog, like he will be so at attention for food that will inevitably drop on the ground.
尼尔森狗，就像他会非常注意不可避免地会掉到地上的食物一样。
So my son is 18 and he is now living away from us at a school for kids with disabilities and young adults with disabilities.
我的儿子 18 岁了，他现在住在远离我们的一所为残疾儿童和残疾年轻人开设的学校。
He has fine motor skill limitations, my son.
我的儿子，他的精细运动技能有限。
He can play, but the miracle, he's an atypical nerd.
他可以打球，但奇迹是，他是一个非典型的书呆子。
The miracle of music, he can play drums really well.
音乐的奇迹，他打鼓打得真好。
He can play keyboard and piano really well.
他键盘和钢琴弹得非常好。
which requires high motor function.
这需要高运动功能。
Totally, because music is magic in it, like lifts him up in those categories, eating.
完全是这样，因为音乐有魔力，就像让他在这些类别中提升一样，吃饭。
He can't get food consistently in his mouth even in age 18.
即使在 18 岁时，他也无法始终将食物送入嘴里。
He loves food, and a lot of it gets in there, but a lot of it falls.
他喜欢食物，很多食物都进了那里，但也有很多食物掉下来。
The person, the being that is the most heartbroken that my son is living away from us is Sally the dog.
我的儿子离开我们生活，让我最心碎的人就是狗莎莉。
Because Sally would just hang out underneath his spot at dinner and just really score.
因为莎莉会在晚餐时在他的位置下面闲逛，并且真正得分。
It was probably Elliot's way of just having fun and feeding the dog.
这可能是埃利奥特玩乐和喂狗的方式。
I know, definitely not.
我知道，绝对不是。
Elliot wanted that food.
艾略特想要那种食物。
It was just falling.
它刚刚坠落。
Oh, he did.
哦，他做到了。
Now he wanted that food.
现在他想要那种食物。
And the dog is like for Lauren, that Elliot's not there anymore.
狗就像劳伦一样，埃利奥特已经不在那里了。
And so it's a hilarious dynamic.
所以这是一个搞笑的动态。
Where now the dog is kind of trying to catch whatever my daughter or we're dropping and it's just not nearly as much of a yield.
现在，狗试图抓住我女儿或我们掉落的任何东西，但产量却没有那么高。
So the dog knows who to go sit under, is my brother.
所以狗知道该去坐在谁的下面，就是我的兄弟。
They're wise beings.
他们是聪明人。
They are wise beings.
I mean, they domesticated themselves.
我的意思是，他们驯化了自己。
Hey, I heard this crazy thing.
嘿，我听到了这疯狂的事情。
Did you hear?
你听到了吗？
They've noticed this in the UK.
他们在英国注意到了这一点。
Foxes, they think, are trying to domesticate themselves and be taken inside as pests.
他们认为，狐狸正试图驯化自己，并作为害虫被带入室内。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
How is that taking form?
这是如何形成的？
What are they doing to this?
他们为此做什么？
They're kind of lurking and like batting their eyelashes of people and just being like, we're harmless.
他们有点潜伏着，喜欢对人眨眼睛，就像我们是无害的。
What's you saying?
你在说什么？
You should take us in and reliably feed us.
你应该收留我们并可靠地喂养我们。
They've noticed how good dogs have it.
他们已经注意到狗的这一点有多好。
Some of the fact check on this.
对此进行了一些事实核查。
Look up, like Foxes domesticated UK something, Alec, you can do it right now.
抬头看，就像狐狸在英国驯化的东西一样，亚历克，你现在就可以做到。
But I think this is really happening, and maybe in a hundred years, it will be totally normal.
但我认为这确实正在发生，也许一百年后，这将是完全正常的。
Fox living with you.
狐狸和你住在一起。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
Yeah.
是的。
What you just told me is my favorite type of Fox news I've ever heard.
你刚才告诉我的是我听过的最喜欢的福克斯新闻类型。
LAUGHTER Also, we're in a news ecosystem where I want to tell people things I've heard, but I'm like, this just might be misinformation.
笑声此外，我们处于一个新闻生态系统中，我想告诉人们我听到的事情，但我想，这可能是错误信息。
I'm speaking wild misinformation.
我说的是疯狂的错误信息。
Am I adding to the case?
我要添加到案例中吗？
But I feel like in the grand scheme of misinformation, you can pass on.
但我觉得在错误信息的宏伟计划中，你可以传递下去。
Fox is trying to domesticate themselves as low.
狐狸正在努力将自己驯化为低等。
Like it's not, the harm for believing that is just like you say at a dinner party and people are like, oh, that's wild.
事实并非如此，相信这一点的危害就像你在晚宴上所说的那样，人们会说，哦，这太疯狂了。
It makes me happy to think of it.
想到这我就很高兴。
Yeah.
是的。
Do you put something positive in the world?
你在世界上放了一些积极的东西吗？
Whether or not it's true, which is very different from a lot of the news that we're getting.
不管这是否属实，这与我们收到的许多消息有很大不同。
I think so.
我想是的。
Yeah, well, also I just wanted us to take a moment.
是的，好吧，我也只是想让我们花点时间。
James Vanderbeek passed away yesterday and we had the honor and the privilege and the pleasure of working with him on how I met your mother.
詹姆斯·范德贝克昨天去世了，我们有幸和他一起研究我是如何认识你母亲的。
He played Robin's high school boyfriend.
他扮演罗宾的高中男友。
Was it Sand Castles?
是沙堡吗？
Was that the episode?
是那一集吗？
Sand Castles in the sand is the episode, the heartbreak ballad kind of that he's in the video of and also represents their relationship back in Canada And he was, yeah, we got, we were so lucky to have him in that episode.
沙子里的沙堡是这一集，是他在视频中出现的令人心碎的民谣，也代表了他们在加拿大的关系。他是，是的，我们得到了，我们很幸运能有他在那一集中。
And he was, I'm gonna, I recorded something, I'm gonna post it after we're done here, but I just found him to be like an incredibly kind cool, grounded, kind of down-to-earth guy.
他是，我要，我录了一些东西，我会在我们完成这里后发布它，但我发现他是一个非常酷、脚踏实地、脚踏实地的人。
And he was also so effortlessly funny in that role.
而且他在这个角色中也毫不费力地搞笑。
It is a wild performance, like it is so funny.
这是一场疯狂的表演，好像很有趣。
So the gist of it is, which I thought you guys really captured something so smart, which is the person you love when you're 14 or 15, like love, like your heart pounds out of your chest when they walk in the room.
所以它的要点是，我认为你们真的捕捉到了一些非常聪明的东西，那就是你在 14 或 15 岁时所爱的人，就像爱，就像当他们走进房间时你的心会从胸口跳出来。
No matter what happens to them over the next couple decades, when they walk in the room where you hear their name, you will still break out in a sweat.
无论他们在接下来的几十年里发生了什么，当他们走进你听到他们名字的房间时，你仍然会出一身冷汗。
You will still, they will always be in the pantheon, Mount Rushmore of your greatest, greatest crushes, right?
你仍然会，他们将永远在万神殿中，你最伟大的迷恋的拉什莫尔山，对吧？
And so you see him when he's younger and he's like this hot young James Vanderbeek as we know it, and then he shows up and he's just, the years have not been kind to him, right?
所以你在他年轻的时候看到他，他就像我们所知道的年轻性感的詹姆斯·范德贝克，然后他出现了，他只是，岁月对他并不友善，对吧？
Yes, yes, absolutely.
是的，是的，绝对是的。
And the gang is all like, this is the guy that- He's balding, he's got a punch, he's unemployed, he still drives the same van.
这帮人都是这样的，就是这个人——他秃头了，他挨了一拳，他失业了，他仍然开着同一辆货车。
But with the same arrogance.
却有着同样的傲慢。
The same arrogance totally, it has a swagger and it totally still works on Robin spurring this concept of a river to go.
完全一样的傲慢，它有一种趾高气扬的感觉，而且它仍然对罗宾起作用，激发了河流的概念。
Where someone from your past comes in your life now and you revert back to who you were when you initially were under their thumb, as it were.
过去的某个人现在出现在你的生活中，你又回到了最初受他们控制时的样子。
And he was so game and daring to come play so against type, against the leading man, against the heart-throb.
他是如此的顽强和敢于与类型、与男主角、与心动的人对抗。
Well, he got to kind of do it and then undermine it.
好吧，他必须先这样做，然后再破坏它。
Do it, yeah, set it up and back in the flashbacks in the video and then complete the undermine it, but still have that charisma and control over Robin.
做吧，是的，将其设置并返回到视频中的闪回中，然后完成破坏它，但仍然具有对罗宾的魅力和控制力。
That's sort of like, mind-mindful.
有点像，用心思考。
And he knew he had it.
他知道他拥有它。
It was like a cult leader's confidence.
这就像一个邪教领袖的自信。
like they're gonna do what I tell.
就像他们会按照我说的做。
Yes, it was a cult leader's confidence and he had this wonderfully kind of almost sweet way about him.
是的，这是一个邪教领袖的自信，他身上有一种奇妙的近乎甜蜜的方式。
Like, I'm sorry, I'm dumping you for Louise Marsh.
就像，对不起，我为了路易丝·马什而抛弃了你。
Like he said it all kind of with a smile on the sweetness.
就像他说这一切时都带着微笑的甜蜜。
He knew exactly how to play this like toxic character in this really sweet way.
他确切地知道如何以这种非常甜蜜的方式扮演这个有毒的角色。
And just was fearless at doing that.
并且无所畏惧地这样做。
It was a really big swing, crazy role.
这是一个非常大的摇摆、疯狂的角色。
And he was just in for it.
而他正是这么做的。
And I wrote you this little ditty to sing to you in New York City.
我给你写了这首小曲，是为了在纽约唱给你听。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
Hey, I'm Carl Radke.
嘿，我是卡尔·拉德克。
You might know me from Bravo Summer House, but on my podcast More Life, I get your favorite reality stars off the clock and into the conversations you don't usually get to hear.
您可能在 Bravo Summer House 认识我，但在我的播客 More Life 中，我会不分昼夜地邀请您最喜欢的真人秀明星进行您通常听不到的对话。
The deep stuff, the vulnerable stuff, the uncomfortable stuff.
深层的东西，脆弱的东西，不舒服的东西。
I've sat down with Sierra Miller, Derinda Medley, Tom Schwartz, Lindsey Hubbard, and a whole lot more.
我与塞拉·米勒 (Sierra Miller)、德林达·梅德利 (Derinda Medley)、汤姆·施瓦茨 (Tom Schwartz)、林赛·哈伯德 (Lindsey Hubbard) 等人进行了交谈。
We get into relationships growing up, the messy stuff, and everything that happens when the cameras aren't rolling.
我们在成长过程中会陷入人际关系，遇到混乱的事情，以及摄像机不转动时发生的一切。
New episodes of More Life every week, listen wherever you get your podcasts or watch on YouTube.
More Life 每周都有新剧集，无论您在哪里收听播客或在 YouTube 上观看。
And now, back to the show.
现在，回到节目。
I saw Carter posted something really lovely about the kind of consideration when you guys were casting him.
我看到卡特发布了一些关于你们选角时的考虑的非常可爱的内容。
It's kind of like, well, James Vanderbeek's not a comic actor.
这有点像詹姆斯·范德贝克不是喜剧演员。
He's not, you know, he doesn't do big comedy like this.
你知道，他不演这样的大喜剧。
And it was such a, sometimes, I mean, I think great actors can do all of it.
有时，我的意思是，我认为伟大的演员可以做到这一切。
But there was something, I sometimes think that, you know, there's always the thing of comic actors can do drama really well.
但有一些事情，我有时会想，你知道，喜剧演员总能把戏剧演得很好。
But often the reverse, like people who can really play it grounded and sincere, but also like really go for it.
但往往恰恰相反，喜欢真正能够脚踏实地、真诚地发挥它的人，但也喜欢真正去追求它。
Like, I just saw, I don't know why, out of a lot of guest star performances, and we had countless guest star performances, James just really stays with me.
就像，我刚刚看到，我不知道为什么，在很多客串明星表演中，我们有无数的客串明星表演，詹姆斯真的和我在一起。
Oh yeah.
哦，是的。
Like, I remember when he, you know, we rehearsed with him that week, but I remember seeing him in his full, like, hair and makeup as the older guy, and just the way he kind of wore it with, yeah, like with this kind of like, I don't know, like, unearned confidence, Like, it really tickled me and I just also, you know, we just, it's hard to explain, but when you're a series regular and people come and guest star, I always tried to be a good host.
就像，我记得当他，你知道，那周我们和他一起排练的时候，但我记得看到他像个老家伙一样，穿着完整的发型和妆容，就像他穿衣服的方式一样，是的，就像这样，我不知道，就像，不劳而获的自信，就像，这真的让我很痒，我也，你知道，我们只是，很难解释，但是当你是一个系列常客，人们来客串明星时，我总是试图成为一个好主人。
Like I felt like people were coming into my house, you know, and are our house.
我感觉人们走进了我的房子，你知道，而且是我们的房子。
And I always tried to be warm and welcoming and help them, because guest starring can be, Even if you're a well-known actor, it can be- It's really hard.
我总是尽力表现出热情和欢迎并帮助他们，因为客串可能是，即使你是一位知名演员，也可能是 - 这真的很难。
It's actually the hardest thing to come into someone.
事实上，进入一个人的内心是最难的。
You're parachuting in for this really good time.
你正在跳伞，享受这美好的时光。
And you're often given crazy stuff to do that requires a certain amount of risk.
而且你经常会被要求去做一些疯狂的事情，而这需要一定的风险。
But I just remember him being, like, an incredibly kind, like, very easy to be around, you know.
但我只记得他是一个非常友善、非常容易相处的人，你知道。
And there wasn't, you know, he was a huge star from Dawson's Creek and from Varsity Blues.
事实并非如此，你知道，他是来自道森溪和大学蓝调的巨星。
but there was no sense that he thought of himself other than just like another person on the set doing the job, you know?
但他并没有把自己看作是片场另一个正在做这项工作的人，你知道吗？
Yeah, an actor who wanted to act and do different things.
是的，一个想要表演并做不同事情的演员。
And that's why he was so up to do something different because people do get so pigeonholed.
这就是为什么他如此愿意做一些不同的事情，因为人们确实会被分类。
I remember when Alexis Stanisoff came on Ali's husband and was so funny as Sandy Rivers.
我记得当亚历克西斯·斯坦尼索夫（Alexis Stanisoff）出现在阿里的丈夫身上时，他和桑迪·里弗斯（Sandy Rivers）一样有趣。
Remember Alison had this good line, she said, you well, Alexis is a character actor trapped in a leading man's body.
记得艾莉森有句很好的台词，她说，你好吧，亚历克西斯是一个被困在男主角身体里的角色演员。
Alexis is very handsome, James Vanderbeek was very handsome, and didn't always, right, people would write off like, oh, he can't be this big broad community character.
亚历克西斯很英俊，詹姆斯·范德贝克也很英俊，但并不总是如此，对吧，人们会认为，哦，他不可能是这个大而广泛的社区人物。
But if you give someone who's a really good actor the way that James was and Alexis too, and you give them that opportunity, you can be so pleasantly surprised.
但如果你给一个像詹姆斯和亚历克西斯那样真正优秀的演员，并给他们这个机会，你会感到非常惊喜。
And that's what it was.
事情就是这样。
He came in and just stole scenes and stole the show, and was so having, clearly having a great time finally getting the chance to do something more like that.
他进来后就抢尽风头，抢尽风头，而且很开心，显然玩得很开心，终于有机会做更多类似的事情了。
And was so, so had the talent to do it.
确实如此，所以有能力做到这一点。
And I just remember him being fearless, but not show offy, not like, I'm gonna take over this scene.
我只记得他无所畏惧，但不炫耀，不像，我要接管这个场景。
He was just so good that he popped in these scenes.
他太棒了，以至于他出现在这些场景中。
He wasn't trying to steal the scenes, he just kind of was because he was so funny and charismatic and this weird off-kilter way in that role and the way you hadn't seen him.
他并不是想抢戏，他只是因为他是如此有趣和有魅力，而且在这个角色中表现出一种奇怪的不平衡的方式，就像你没有见过他一样。
And just the kindest and funniest, he was a great, just a great person to come play with us a few times and I really got nothing but positive good energy off of him.
最友善、最有趣的是，他是一个很棒的人，和我们一起玩了几次，我真的从他身上得到了积极的能量。
I was so sad to see him pass at this young age.
看到他这么年轻就去世了，我感到非常难过。
I'm so sorry for his family and everybody who loved him and all his fans and we're fans of his two and we're sharing that sorrow.
我为他的家人、所有爱他的人和他所有的粉丝感到非常抱歉，我们是他两个的粉丝，我们正在分享这种悲伤。
So we were lucky that our paths got to cross with his.
所以我们很幸运，我们的道路与他的道路交叉。
Yeah, and I'll just share this again because I'm gonna post this video that I did last night but one of the things that really struck me about him and it only occurred to me when I really started thinking about it last night, I would see these videos over the years that he would post And sometimes he would post like, this is how you fix this thing around your house.
是的，我会再次分享这个，因为我要发布我昨晚做的这个视频，但他真正让我印象深刻的一件事是当我昨晚真正开始思考它时才想到的，多年来我会看到他发布的这些视频有时他会发布这样的内容，这就是你如何解决你家周围的这个问题。
Like he seemed like he was a real like handyman father, you know?
他看起来就像一个真正的勤杂工父亲，你知道吗？
And there was something so generous about it.
这其中有一些非常慷慨的东西。
Like, hey, if anyone's struggling with this, like this is a quick, easy fix.
就像，嘿，如果有人为此苦苦挣扎，就像这是一个快速、简单的解决方案。
But he would also share things he had learned, wisdom, stuff he wanted to share, especially once he got sick and things seemed to coalesce in different ways for him.
但他也会分享他学到的东西、智慧、他想分享的东西，尤其是当他生病时，事情似乎以不同的方式融合在一起。
And, but I think, you know, People don't understand that getting famous, getting well-known, having that spotlight put on you when you're on a hit show or your anonymity of roads and suddenly you're thought of as something different than other people your age.
而且，但我认为，你知道，人们不明白，出名、出名、在热门节目中成为众人瞩目的焦点，或者在道路上默默无闻，突然间，你会被认为与同龄人不同。
And he was young, when I did the pilot of how I met mother, I think I was 29 or 30, I had a bunch of decades under my belt as not known.
他还很年轻，当我拍摄《我是如何遇见母亲》的试播集时，我想我大概 29 岁或 30 岁，我已经有好几十年不为人知了。
So that had its own challenges, but to be a teenager And have that happen?
所以这有其自身的挑战，但作为一个青少年，这种情况会发生吗？
You know, Neil and Ali had that.
你知道，尼尔和阿里就有这样的经历。
I never have.
我从来没有。
But it can be so disorienting, so vertigo-inducing.
但它可能会让人迷失方向，让人头晕。
And of course, the history is littered with child actors who kind of don't make it out of that vortex.
当然，历史上充斥着无法摆脱这种漩涡的儿童演员。
But the thing that I found so kind of achingly sweet and moving about James when I would see these videos, I was like, this is a guy that could have gotten frozen and just really stepped into being a man and a husband and a father.
但当我看到这些视频时，我发现詹姆斯是如此的甜蜜和动人，我想，这是一个本来可以被冻结的人，却真正成为了一个男人、一个丈夫和一个父亲。
And so joyfully, he looked like he really loved having a gaggle of kids and being the man of the house and I just found it very moving.
令人高兴的是，他看起来真的很喜欢有一群孩子并成为家里的男主人，我觉得这非常令人感动。
And it was an extension of the person we met on set.
这是我们在片场遇到的那个人的延伸。
I don't remember how many kids he had like when he was on set.
我不记得他在片场的时候喜欢过多少个孩子。
But yeah, like you said, Craig, I'm just sending a lot of love to his wife into his, to his family and, and also to the, you know, there's always a, a sense of loss when, when people you grew up watching and relating to, and people say this all the time about how it made your mother and it was certainly true of Dawson's Creek.
但是，是的，就像你说的，克雷格，我只是向他的妻子，向他的家人，还有，你知道，当你长大后看着并与之相关的人时，总会有一种失落感，人们总是说这如何造就了你的母亲，这对道森溪来说确实如此。
My wife, you know, absolutely never meant, you know, so I have an episode and there's something about like, these characters teach you something profound about life, you know, he modeled something, you know, It wasn't on Ted like his role on that show.
我的妻子，你知道，绝对不是故意的，你知道，所以我有一集，这些角色教会了你一些关于生活的深刻的东西，你知道，他模仿了一些东西，你知道，这不像泰德在那个节目中的角色。
He modeled a kind of open part of it.
他模拟了其中的一种开放部分。
He was the Ted of that show, absolutely, yeah.
他绝对是那个节目中的泰德，是的。
So, and yet another reason it was fun to give him a role that was kind of vicious in its own way, you know?
所以，给他一个本身就有点邪恶的角色很有趣，还有一个原因，你知道吗？
So, it was so different and he just so took joy in just being a good actor and doing, I'm gonna do some, I'm gonna show you I can do something else.
所以，这是非常不同的，他非常高兴成为一名好演员，并且做一些事情，我会告诉你我可以做其他事情。
And I hope more really handsome actors are given more roles like that.
我希望更多真正帅气的演员能扮演更多这样的角色。
I'm like, what are we, what, what, Alexis got my hope is that more handsome actors get more work.
我想，我们是什么，什么，什么，亚历克西斯得到我的希望是更英俊的演员得到更多的工作。
I would like to see, yeah, get more on a handsome roles, I guess I would say, but he was, he had so much fun playing with that role.
我想看到，是的，更多地扮演一个帅气的角色，我想我会说，但他是，他扮演这个角色非常有趣。
And I think you're right, Josh, like that's that you're even in that role, you saw a guy who was not trying to be frozen in some other earlier image or of himself.
我认为你是对的，乔什，就像你在那个角色中一样，你看到一个人并没有试图被冻结在其他早期的形象或他自己中。
He was saying, I very much welcome the idea of being supple and present in this new form and finding new ways to evolve and have fun.
他说，我非常欢迎以这种新形式保持柔软和呈现的想法，并寻找新的发展方式和乐趣。
and be curious.
并保持好奇心。
And he just seemed like he embodies the spirit.
他似乎体现了这种精神。
And I think that's a bit of a secret to life, is like let yourself age, like let yourself grow, let yourself change, like don't freeze yourself, don't venerate or fetishize any stage you're at, as like the best or the worst, or just keep going and that's what I saw him do.
我认为这是生活的一个秘密，就像让自己变老，让自己成长，让自己改变，比如不要冻结自己，不要崇拜或迷恋你所处的任何阶段，无论是最好的还是最坏的，或者只是继续前进，这就是我看到他所做的。
So just, yeah, sending a lot of love to James and to his family and we're so sad about it.
所以，是的，向詹姆斯和他的家人致以很多爱，我们对此感到非常难过。
but we're so grateful we got to spend some time with him.
但我们非常感激我们能和他一起度过一些时间。
And so moved about all the wonderful comments we're seeing from how much mother fans who loved him on the show so much, he really scored and echoed.
我们从节目中如此喜爱他的母亲粉丝那里看到的所有精彩评论让我们非常感动，他真的得分并回应了。
He hid above his weight of how many times he was on the show.
他在节目中多次隐藏自己的体重。
He was only on the show a few times, but he had an outsized impact.
虽然他只出现过几次节目，但他的影响力却很大。
And I see a lot of him fans being like, I'm watching Sand Councils on this hand today, I'm watching that music video that he's in, I'm crying.
我看到他的很多粉丝都说，我今天在看这手牌的沙理事会，我在看他的音乐录影带，我哭了。
And it's very sweet that we got to have him commemorated in the show and in the way that we did.
我们能够在节目中以我们所做的方式来纪念他，这真是太好了。
So yeah, Alec, let's take some questions.
是的，亚历克，让我们回答一些问题。
Maybe we, maybe we full of wanna talk about this.
也许我们，也许我们很想谈论这个。
We have a lot of stuff going on here.
我们这里有很多事情要做。
Let me see where it starts.
让我看看它从哪里开始。
So first of all, you do remember he talks about his parents having a Jacuzz and okay, Kev.
首先，你确实记得他谈到他的父母有一个按摩浴缸，好吧，凯夫。
It was Louise Marsh's parents and he was staying with her because they were really upgrading their pool patio situation, so he was choosing to be with her again instead of Robin.
那是路易丝·马什的父母，他和她住在一起，因为他们确实正在升级他们的泳池露台，所以他选择再次和她在一起，而不是罗宾。
Well, okay, Kevin, he says, hoping that God has a jacuzz for him.
好吧，凯文，他说，希望上帝为他准备了一个按摩浴缸。
Oh, he was funny with that jacuzz line.
哦，他的按摩浴缸线很有趣。
Yeah, a lot of really nice.
是的，很多真的很好。
That was him justifying the breakup to Robin.
那是他向罗宾解释分手的理由。
Robin's reaction was kind of like, yeah, I get it, it's a jacuzz.
罗宾的反应有点像，是的，我明白了，这是一个按摩浴缸。
What are you going to do?
你会怎样做？
A lot of really nice notes for about him.
有很多关于他的非常好的笔记。
And Fatima.assif.mirisa says he had a complicated relationship with the character of Dawson and is embracing of it over the years was a public evolution for those of us paying attention.
Fatima.assif.mirisa 表示，他与道森这个角色有着复杂的关系，多年来对这一角色的接受对于我们这些关注的人来说是一种公共演变。
So a lot of James fans on here.
这里有很多詹姆斯球迷。
And a lot of overlap to things Josh has talked about and we've had other people talk about on this podcast and yeah, it's interesting.
乔什谈论的事情有很多重叠，我们也让其他人在这个播客上谈论过，是的，这很有趣。
I feel like Josh, like we all, we all went to the same college, we all went to college at the same time.
我觉得乔什和我们所有人一样，我们都上同一所大学，我们都同时上大学。
It's that same feeling.
就是同样的感觉。
but the office ladies too, like there's some sense in which we were all in this game together at the same moment and the idea that he had some of the same journeys or struggles as you.
但办公室女士们也一样，就像我们在同一时刻一起参与这个游戏一样，并且认为他和你有一些相同的旅程或挣扎。
It's such a small specific club.
这是一个很小的特定俱乐部。
It is.
这是。
It's not, I mean, if you have a big empathetic imagination, like my wife who has never been on a hit TV show as a series regular, has deep kind of empathy around this and that's one of the ways I just felt like, oh, this is, I need actually someone to understand this.
我的意思是，如果你有很强的同理心想象力，就像我的妻子一样，她从未作为连续剧的常客出现在热门电视节目中，但对此有深刻的同理心，这就是我的感觉之一，哦，这是，我实际上需要有人来理解这一点。
If I'm gonna, you know, but, you know, to really be able to drop in, because everyone wants you to celebrate the good fortune of it, but everything has a tax, everything has a shadow, everything, all good fortune.
如果我要去，你知道，但是，你知道，真的能够顺便拜访一下，因为每个人都希望你庆祝它的好运，但一切都有税，一切都有阴影，一切，都是好运。
Yes, well said.
是的，说得好。
Has a shadow, has a tax, and it's really nice to be able to be honest about that without feeling like you have to apologize or bend over backwards to say, you know, I know I appreciate it.
有阴影，有税收，能够诚实地对待这一点，而不需要道歉或竭尽全力地说，你知道，我知道我很感激，这真的很好。
And all of that is true too.
所有这些也是如此。
You have to work to feel the gratitude and kind of pinch yourself that your life has gotten weird and interesting and amazing and also more complicated.
你必须努力去感受感激之情，并有点掐自己，因为你的生活变得奇怪、有趣、令人惊奇，也变得更加复杂。
Yeah, awesome.
是啊，太棒了。
Couple of things here.
这里有几件事。
I'm just gonna say this for people listening here.
我只是想对在这里聆听的人们说这些。
We are not going to get into politics on this Instagram live and a lot of people are expressing a lot of the political opinions in this chat here.
我们不会在 Instagram 直播中谈论政治，很多人都在这里的聊天中表达了很多政治观点。
And so we're gonna ask you to hold that off for somewhere else and at a certain point, we will just have to a block you from this because a lot of people are trying to get in there.
因此，我们会要求您将其推迟到其他地方，并且在某个时候，我们将不得不阻止您这样做，因为很多人都试图进入那里。
How I met your mother questions and people have very important things to say.
我是如何认识你母亲的问题，人们有非常重要的事情要说。
This is not quite the right place to say it, but thank you to everyone.
虽然这个地方不太合适，但还是谢谢大家。
So let's hear where people are from.
那么让我们听听人们来自哪里。
This is not, it's ready, ready?
这不，已经准备好了，准备好了吗？
Brazil, the Netherlands, France, Iran, India, England, Italy, Ecuador, Turkey, Ukraine, Egypt, Vietnam, Poland, Germany, Argentina, and of course, Canada.
巴西、荷兰、法国、伊朗、印度、英国、意大利、厄瓜多尔、土耳其、乌克兰、埃及、越南、波兰、德国、阿根廷，当然还有加拿大。
Wow.
哇。
I can't believe no one from the US tuned in, but that's fine.
我不敢相信美国没有人收看，但这没关系。
We'll have...
我们会有...
Not zero.
不为零。
We'll have, yeah.
我们会有的，是的。
Oh, we have, now we're adding in Ghana.
哦，我们有，现在我们要添加加纳。
We'll do the Arizona.
我们会做亚利桑那号。
Oh, Arizona tuned in.
哦，亚利桑那州调过来了。
Okay, great.
好的，太好了。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
We have Ghana and the Czech Republic and Philippines and Nepal, amazing stuff.
我们有加纳、捷克共和国、菲律宾和尼泊尔，这些都是很棒的国家。
That's so cool.
太酷了。
Hello, everybody.
大家好。
Thanks for joining us.
感谢您加入我们。
So, Austria.
那么，奥地利。
So everyone here throwing some questions here for the guys.
所以这里的每个人都向大家提出一些问题。
You do have them, it's actually live.
你确实有它们，它实际上是实时的。
They're actually humans here live.
他们实际上是生活在这里的人类。
They can answer your questions.
他们可以回答您的问题。
Craig, here's an important one.
克雷格，这是一个重要的事情。
Ka underscore ton 35, 35, oh five asks, can I open a bar called puzzles or is that patented?
Ka下划线吨35，35，哦五问，我可以打开一个名为拼图的酒吧吗？或者这是专利吗？
Um, it's not, I mean, I don't know why it is.
嗯，不是，我的意思是，我不知道为什么会这样。
It owns the world puzzles now, don't they?
它现在拥有了世界谜题，不是吗？
Disney might only idea of a bar being called puzzles on a TV show.
迪士尼可能只是在电视节目中将酒吧称为“拼图”。
I don't know about it in real life, but, uh, I'm going to just go ahead and open your bar puzzles.
我在现实生活中不知道，但是，呃，我要继续打开你的酒吧谜题。
I think I'm my, my old man brain is, is really struggling to remember, but I think someone did.
我想我是我的，我老人家的大脑，真的很难记住，但我想有人做到了。
I think someone opened a bar called puzzles in honor of how much a mother it may be in Texas.
我想有人开了一家名为“拼图”的酒吧，以纪念德克萨斯州的一位母亲。
I, I, can someone check me out on this in real time?
我，我，有人可以实时查看我的情况吗？
I wonder if you get a free drink.
我想知道你是否能得到一杯免费饮料。
If you say, why is it called puzzles?
如果你说，为什么叫拼图呢？
That's the puzzle.
这就是谜题。
If you know the reference, you get a free drink.
如果您知道参考号，您将获得一杯免费饮料。
Yeah, so I think, I'm gonna say, I think there's a place called puzzles in Texas, puzzles deep, Elum, and I've interacted with these folks online, I'm looking it up, there is, it's in Lakewood East Dallas, there is a puzzles in tribute to how I'm a true mother.
是的，所以我想，我想说，我想在德克萨斯州有一个叫做谜题的地方，谜题很深，Elum，我在网上与这些人互动，我查了一下，那里，在达拉斯东莱克伍德，有一个谜题向我如何成为一个真正的母亲致敬。
So that does exist, my old man-brand was not fooling me.
所以这确实存在，我的老男人品牌并没有愚弄我。
But I think if it's out of Texas, There could be more puzzles.
但我认为如果是在德克萨斯州之外，可能会有更多的谜题。
If they're in the way with it, I guess they're a good, they're like trying to travel down the Dallas puzzles.
如果他们妨碍了，我想他们是个好人，他们就像试图沿着达拉斯的谜题旅行。
Maybe now that I'm called them out, it will happen, but I hope not.
也许现在我被叫出来了，这种事就会发生，但我希望不会。
I remember they reached out to me and I was like, that's very cool, there's a bar called puzzles and it's contributing to me.
我记得他们联系了我，我说，这太酷了，有一个叫做“拼图”的酒吧，它对我有帮助。
We should open a bar.
我们应该开一家酒吧。
Yeah, we should do it.
是的，我们应该这样做。
Peyton Puless.
佩顿·普莱斯。
Manning.
曼宁.
Peyton.
佩顿。
That'd be huge.
那将是巨大的。
I don't know what that's good question.
我不知道什么是好问题。
says, I'm so glad this podcast is a thing.
说，我很高兴有这个播客。
Why aren't you guys on YouTube anymore?
你们为什么不再上 YouTube 了？
That's pretty much.
差不多了。
But we do have a lot of people just, again, excited that there's a podcast.
但我们确实有很多人再次对播客的出现感到兴奋。
And I'm just saying, sorry, Alex, I talk over you.
我只是说，对不起，亚历克斯，我在替你说话。
Oh, no, no, I'm just saying that we have a lot of people excited that there's a podcast.
哦，不，不，我只是说我们有很多人对播客感到兴奋。
And part of also why we're doing this here is to announce this to the world.
我们在这里这样做的部分原因是向世界宣布这一点。
So if you guys just want to give a one minute ad for this thing that we're doing, what are we doing here?
所以，如果你们只是想为我们正在做的事情做一分钟的广告，我们在这里做什么？
Well, I'll just recap how it happened, which was my wife, Jordana had never seen how I met your mother.
好吧，我就简单回顾一下事情是怎么发生的，那是我的妻子，乔丹娜从来没有见过我是怎么认识你母亲的。
She knew I was on the show.
她知道我在节目中。
She had seen the enthusiasm with which people, in many cities would come up and express how much they loved the show.
她看到许多城市的人们热情地站出来表达他们对这个节目的喜爱程度。
And she said, I would like to watch it.
她说，我想看。
I missed this whole huge chapter of your life, and I'd really like to see what this was.
我错过了你人生中这一重要的篇章，我真的很想看看这是什么。
So I immediately called Craig and I said, I'm gonna start watching the show again with Jordana, but do you wanna do something a little more formal?
所以我立即打电话给克雷格，我说，我要开始和乔丹娜一起再次观看节目，但是你想做一些更正式的事情吗？
Like, do you wanna re-watch it with me and do a, you know, let's do a podcast.
就像，你想和我一起重看它吗？然后做一个，你知道的，让我们做一个播客。
Let's re-watch it and see now that we're older, closer to the narrator Ted's age.
让我们再看一遍，看看我们现在年纪大了，更接近叙述者特德的年龄。
Let's look back on this chapter in our life and see what's there.
让我们回顾一下人生的这一章，看看其中有什么。
And then we immediately called Alec Lev, our producer who was the entire charge of digital content for years on How I Make Your Mother, also Craig Steer friend from college from Wesleyan, and also was the hosted How I Make Your Mother podcast, which I appeared on a number of times, to be our producer, and then here we are.
然后我们立即打电话给我们的制作人亚历克·列夫（Alec Lev），他多年来一直负责《如何让你的母亲》的数字内容，也是来自卫斯理大学的克雷格·斯蒂尔的朋友，也是我多次出现在《如何让你的母亲》播客的主持人，让他担任我们的制作人，然后我们就到了。
We've got two seasons under our belt.
我们已经有两个赛季了。
The audience is enthusiastic and delightful and growing.
观众热情高涨，心情愉悦，不断成长。
We're trying to grow it a little bit more or a lot more, because there's a lot more Hymnium fans out there that probably don't even know we're doing this.
我们正在努力让它变得更多一点或更多，因为有更多的 Hymnium 粉丝可能甚至不知道我们正在这样做。
So we'd love more people to journey through this show with us.
所以我们希望更多的人能和我们一起经历这个节目。
We're learning so much more about the show that we made as we do this podcast.
当我们制作这个播客时，我们对我们制作的节目有了更多的了解。
Would you say that, Craig?
克雷格，你会这么说吗？
Yeah, I'm learning so much more.
是的，我正在学习更多。
I'm seeing it in such a different way.
我以不同的方式看待它。
It is so interesting to be 50 looking at the show that we're doing in our 30s.
50 岁看我们 30 多岁做的节目真是太有趣了。
And we really are our almost future TEDs age now.
我们现在确实是即将到来的 TED 时代。
It's great.
这很棒。
I was so due for a rewatch.
我真该重看一遍。
I hadn't watched it in years.
我已经好几年没看过了。
My wife always complained she only saw every episode once with me watching her, watching the episode, assessing whether she was laughing at jokes and asking why she didn't.
我的妻子总是抱怨她每集只看了一遍，而我看着她，看这一集，评估她是否因笑话而笑，并问她为什么不笑。
She said it was the least relaxing way to watch a TV show.
她说这是看电视节目最不放松的方式。
Much like Ted watching Stella while she watches Star Wars.
就像泰德在斯特拉看《星球大战》时看着她一样。
This whole thing is that when you're like, with Jordana, I'm like, it really was.
整件事就是，当你和乔丹娜在一起时，我想，确实如此。
I gotta help Jordana likes this.
我得帮助乔丹娜喜欢这个。
It's the same thing as helping Stella like Star Wars, Jordana likes the show.
这就像帮助斯特拉喜欢星球大战一样，乔丹娜喜欢这个节目。
Yeah.
是的。
That's been one thing we've discovered, which is great, but she wants to watch it week by week in real time.
这是我们发现的一件事，这很棒，但她想每周实时观看。
She doesn't want to, every now and again, we have to move.
她不想，时不时地，我们必须搬家。
No, no, she would watch it in like three afternoons.
不不，她大概三个下午就能看完。
Like she wants to barrel through it, like.
就像她想冲过去一样。
Right, but she doesn't want to jump ahead.
是的，但她不想跳到前面。
Some is we have to watch an episode a few ahead of where we really are to do the podcast for a guest and she's like, no.
有些是我们必须在真正为客人制作播客之前观看一集，而她说，不。
It's strange, my marriage when I have to do it.
奇怪的是，我的婚姻当我不得不这么做的时候。
Yeah, you're like, you're going to watch that one alone.
是的，你会想，你会一个人看那个。
We're going in order and you got to respect that.
我们会按顺序进行，你必须尊重这一点。
But yeah, it's been a delight.
但是，是的，这真是令人高兴。
So thanks for joining us.
感谢您加入我们。
And the office ladies who are the best at this and the originators in many ways of the great comedy re-watch podcast, Jenna and Angela.
珍娜和安吉拉是这方面最擅长的白领女士，也是这部伟大喜剧重播播客的多方面创始人。
They took us under their wing.
他们把我们保护在他们的羽翼之下。
We're in business with them.
我们和他们有生意往来。
on their network, and the two shows cross over sometimes, and it's great to talk with them about their journey.
在他们的网络上，两个节目有时会交叉，很高兴与他们谈论他们的旅程。
We've been on their podcast, they've been on ours, we're actually going to, you know, there's some fun, upcoming stuff with them also.
我们一直在他们的播客上，他们一直在我们的播客上，我们实际上也会，你知道，他们也有一些有趣的、即将推出的东西。
Here's an easy one for you, Benny, believe, and actually several people have asked about rain scenes.
本尼，相信这对你来说很简单，实际上有几个人问过关于雨景的问题。
What was it like to film rain and winter scenes and when you were actually in Los Angeles?
当你在洛杉矶拍摄雨天和冬天的场景时，感觉如何？
Was it difficult?
难吗？
How does that work?
这是如何运作的？
Well, I mean, it's better to do a rain scene in Los Angeles than in New York in the winter.
嗯，我的意思是，冬天在洛杉矶拍雨景比在纽约拍更好。
Like, I mean, I remember, I mean, I had to do, we had to do a bunch of rain seeds.
就像，我的意思是，我记得，我的意思是，我必须做，我们必须做一堆雨种子。
I think isn't, so Craig and Carter have said that they pitched Ted Mosby as a cross between Lloyd Dobbler, John Cusack's character from Say Anything, and George Bailey from It's A Wonderful Life.
我认为不是，所以克雷格和卡特表示，他们将泰德·莫斯比视为《说吧》中约翰·库萨克饰演的劳埃德·多布勒和《生活多美好》中乔治·贝利的结合体。
Wasn't that the two?
那不是两个人吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Those are the two touchstones in any way.
无论如何，这都是两个试金石。
And Q-Sack has been called, I believe, the most reigned-upon-actor cinema history.
我相信，《Q-Sack》被称为电影史上最受演员欢迎的电影。
Is that right?
是这样吗？
Yeah.
是的。
He's in a lot of rain scenes.
他出演了很多雨景。
He's holding up that boombox on the rain.
他在雨中举着音箱。
I mean, that is Ted Mosby's spirit animal.
我的意思是，那是泰德·莫斯比的精神动物。
And we knew we wanted to end season one in a big rain scene with you outside.
我们知道我们希望在大雨场景中让你在外面结束第一季。
You know, Ted is outside the girl's house calling up to her in the rain.
你知道，特德在雨中在女孩家外面打电话给她。
It's a very boombox moment.
这是一个非常轰动的时刻。
We knew we wanted that moment.
我们知道我们想要那一刻。
Like, we were going to do that moment.
就像，我们要做那一刻。
So just to explain logistically what happens for rain scenes, at least in how I met your mother, we would go down to the New York Street on the Fox lot, which was a golf cart right away or you could walk it.
因此，为了从逻辑上解释雨景会发生什么，至少在我如何遇见你母亲的过程中，我们会去福克斯停车场的纽约街，那是一辆高尔夫球车，或者你可以步行它。
I like to walk it.
我喜欢步行它。
And they would have this enormous truck with, it looked like a, almost like a cement mixer truck, but it was even bigger, right?
他们会有这辆巨大的卡车，它看起来像，几乎像一辆水泥搅拌车，但它更大，对吧？
And out of it would be coming these huge pipes that would splay out over the stage.
从里面会流出这些巨大的管道，这些管道会在舞台上展开。
And then they'd call it, you know, they'd say, over the street, over New York Street.
然后他们会说，你知道，他们会说，在街上，在纽约街。
Over New York Street, yeah, yeah, yeah.
在纽约大街上，是啊，是啊，是啊。
And it would simulate rain in a pretty realistic way.
它会以非常现实的方式模拟下雨。
I mean, when you were underneath it, you felt like it's raining, you know.
我的意思是，当你在它下面时，你感觉就像在下雨，你知道。
Yeah, hard rain.
是啊，大雨。
Hard rain.
大雨。
It didn't drizzle.
没有下毛毛雨。
It was really hard rain.
雨确实很大。
I don't know if it had a drizzle for it.
不知道是不是下过毛毛细雨。
It would be pretty cold.
天气会很冷。
But also, they would have to put these enormous blockers up, like what do they call it, like tarp kind of things to block out the sun.
而且，他们还必须放置这些巨大的阻挡物，就像他们所说的那样，比如防水布之类的东西来遮挡阳光。
because it was off in sunny in Los Angeles as it is, but it's not off in sunny when it rains.
因为在洛杉矶晴天时它是关闭的，但下雨时它不会在晴天关闭。
So I remember very vividly the end of season one sitting, discovering Marshall, you know, holding up with Robin, like I made it rain, you know, that screaming that.
所以我非常清楚地记得第一季结束时坐着，发现马歇尔，你知道，和罗宾一起坚持，就像我让下雨一样，你知道，尖叫。
But also I have a very strong memory of, I don't remember what season it was, but the hurricane episode where the gang ends up, kind of like dancing, deliriously playing in the rain.
但我也有一个非常强烈的记忆，我不记得那是什么季节，但那帮人最后的飓风情节，有点像跳舞，在雨中疯狂地玩耍。
I remember that because I just remember we had fun and we mostly improvised it.
我记得这一点是因为我只记得我们玩得很开心，而且大部分都是即兴发挥。
I mean, I don't think you guys gave us direction about what we had to do.
我的意思是，我认为你们没有给我们指示我们必须做什么。
It was kind of like, we were just kids in the rain, you know?
有点像，我们只是雨中的孩子，你知道吗？
Yeah, and it's true.
是的，这是真的。
It was always very hard rain and it really felt like a Hollywood production because the tarps that block out the sun are gigantic.
雨一直下得很大，感觉就像好莱坞大片，因为遮挡阳光的防水布很大。
And the rain, like the rain pipes, are way high up.
雨就像雨管一样，很高。
There's a bunch of them and there's like rain really, like with a lot of like fire hose water pressure coming out, it really feels like you're making a big movie when you do that.
有很多这样的东西，真的就像下雨了，就像有很多像消防水带的水压一样，当你这样做的时候，真的感觉就像你在拍一部大电影。
It's cool.
这很酷。
It kind of makes everyone up their game because it feels like, oh, we're making a movie.
这有点让每个人都做好了自己的游戏，因为感觉就像，哦，我们正在拍一部电影。
When we would be on, yeah.
当我们上场的时候，是的。
And there were also you often on the rain things, there'd be a crane to hold the camera.
还有你经常在下雨的东西，会有一个起重机来支撑相机。
Oh, and then the cameras would have like raincoats, remember?
哦，然后相机就会像雨衣一样，还记得吗？
Yeah, they have special camera raincoats.
是的，他们有特殊的相机雨衣。
They have camera raincoats.
他们有相机雨衣。
They look like crab fishermen, like the camera people, yeah.
他们看起来像螃蟹渔民，就像摄影师，是的。
But there was, it's true what you say, like there was something like during those big rain scenes on the Fox lot New York street that I would always have a pinch myself moment where I'd be like, I've really made it in show business.
但你说的是真的，就像在纽约福克斯大街上的那些大雨场景中，我总会有一个捏自己的时刻，我会想，我真的在演艺界取得了成功。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
I really did it.
我真的做到了。
Was there a sense of pressure?
有没有一种压力感？
Like, I gotta deliver in this rain scene.
就像，我必须在这个雨景中交付。
There's only so much rain that we're gonna get, right?
我们只会下这么多雨，对吗？
Well, yeah.
嗯，是的。
And there's a lot of money.
而且有很多钱。
And it's like, I've got rain.
就像，我下雨了。
I never thought I'm gonna screw this up so much that we run out of rain.
我从来没想过我会把事情搞砸到我们没雨了。
I never had to have thought.
我从来不需要思考。
But I did, you know, sometimes there are certain things that you have to do as an actor that require an enormous amount of imagination because you're not actually experiencing the conditions.
但我确实做到了，你知道，有时作为一名演员，你必须做一些需要大量想象力的事情，因为你并没有真正经历这些条件。
But there's something about getting rained on that is so real and visceral and tactile that it puts you in the scene in a different way.
但淋雨的感觉是如此真实、发自内心、触感十足，让你以一种不同的方式置身于场景之中。
Like when you're underneath, you know, the balcony screaming up to Robin and rain is just pelting you.
就像当你在下面时，你知道，阳台向罗宾尖叫，而雨水正向你袭来。
And you're like, I made it rain!
你会说，我让天下雨了！
Like that's easier to do while it's raining on you, right?
就像下雨的时候更容易做到这一点，对吗？
It puts you in some sort of mood.
它让你处于某种心情中。
So yeah, I love the rained scenes, yeah.
所以是的，我喜欢下雨的场景，是的。
You always had great energy in those scenes is my point.
我的观点是，你在那些场景中总是充满活力。
Like I felt you like bringing it.
就像我觉得你喜欢带它一样。
Well, wakes you up.
嗯，叫醒你。
I'm saying for sure.
我肯定地说。
Like I said, it wasn't warm water.
就像我说的，这不是温水。
And very quickly, Michelle McNeil O'9 gave us season seven, episode nine, disaster averted.
很快，米歇尔·麦克尼尔·O'9 给我们带来了第七季第九集，灾难避免了。
I believe as the episode you were talking about there.
我相信正如你在那里谈论的那一集。
Yeah, yeah, disaster averted.
是啊是啊，灾难避免了。
That's right.
这是正确的。
Well done.
干得好。
And now, commercials.
现在，广告。
End of commercials, back to show.
广告结束，回到节目。
Fatima.assif.mirza just texted me saying, I know I have so many good questions, you don't have to say my name each time, just ask all two questions.
Fatima.assif.mirza 刚刚给我发短信说，我知道我有很多好问题，你不必每次都说出我的名字，只需问全部两个问题即可。
I just wanna point out, you do a fantastic question, so keep them coming.
我只是想指出，你提出了一个很棒的问题，所以让他们继续来。
Thanks Fatima.
谢谢法蒂玛。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
We're calling you out, we're giving you credit, we don't care, stop being so modest.
我们在呼唤你，我们在给予你荣誉，我们不在乎，别再谦虚了。
We'll keep this one short, so I'm gonna ask one more question from Fatima here, which is what was the, because we did just finish, as we said, recording our season two recaps.
我们会保持这个简短，所以我要问法蒂玛另一个问题，这是什么，因为我们刚刚完成，正如我们所说，记录我们的第二季回顾。
We still have several more to drop, as I say, in the podcast world.
正如我所说，在播客世界中，我们还有更多东西要放弃。
But so Fatima, as a review says, what was the most important shift in writing for the series in season two?
但法蒂玛，正如评论所说，该剧第二季写作中最重要的转变是什么？
Did you make intentional changes in narrative structure or content?
您是否有意改变叙事结构或内容？
Yeah, watching season two had became clear to me, maybe even clearer than it was at the time we really switched to the condition of the characters, right?
是的，观看第二季对我来说已经变得清晰起来，甚至可能比我们真正切换到角色状况时更清晰，对吧？
We meet Ted in the pilot and he's like, I'm the single guy and there's this couple.
我们在试播集中遇到了泰德，他说，我是单身汉，而有这对情侣。
Season two is Marshall's the single guy and Ted and Robin are this couple and now Barney has also lost his wingman.
第二季是马歇尔的单身汉，泰德和罗宾是这对情侣，现在巴尼也失去了他的僚机。
So like all of those new conditions in season two were so rich.
就像第二季中的所有新条件都非常丰富一样。
I felt like we really did an interesting shuffling of the deck of cards in the beginning of season two and I'm loving season two because it really paid off.
我觉得我们在第二季开始时确实对牌进行了有趣的洗牌，我喜欢第二季，因为它确实得到了回报。
It was a lot of big moves.
这是很多大动作。
The network wasn't completely convinced of how many big moves were ending season one on, to put it mildly.
温和地说，电视网并不完全相信第一季结束时会有多少大动作。
And I guess I'm feeling a little vindicated when I watch season two, I'm going, no, we needed to make all those big moves to give ourselves fuel for new stories and to see new speeds of these characters.
我想当我观看第二季时，我感觉有点平反了，我想说，不，我们需要做出所有这些大动作，为自己提供新故事的动力，并看到这些角色的新速度。
And the same's gonna be true with the end of season two heading into season three, the condition really shifts again.
同样的情况也会发生在第二季结束进入第三季时，情况真的再次发生了变化。
And I just think you have to do that.
我只是认为你必须这样做。
It's what it's what enables you to find out more about these characters.
这就是让您能够更多地了解这些角色的原因。
you've got to mix it up, right?
你必须把它混合起来，对吧？
You've got to evolve.
你必须进化。
We're saying this about Mr. Vanderbeek earlier, like you've got to find new speeds, right?
我们之前谈到过范德贝克先生，就像你必须找到新的速度一样，对吧？
That's like, if you're an artist, like you've got to try to challenge yourself, you've got to paint yourself into some new corners and see how you get out of it.
这就像，如果你是一名艺术家，你必须尝试挑战自己，你必须将自己描绘成一些新的角落，然后看看如何摆脱它。
And that's what I'm getting out of watching season two.
这就是我观看第二季的收获。
I'm realizing like we really, we changed the genetic makeup of the show without losing what was special about the show.
我意识到我们确实改变了节目的基因构成，但又没有失去节目的特别之处。
But yeah, Ted and Robin are the couple and Marshall's the single guy for a while.
但是，是的，泰德和罗宾是情侣，而马歇尔暂时单身。
And that was really fun on the ride.
旅途中真的很有趣。
Yeah, you know, one thing that I have been struck by for both seasons as we've been watching, I remember Bruce who was, I think, C-camera or B-camera operator for the whole time.
是的，你知道，在我们观看的两季中，有一件事让我印象深刻，我记得布鲁斯，我认为他一直是 C 机或 B 机操作员。
Yeah, Bruce said to me, because he'd been on a lot of long running shows, he said, maybe after like halfway through season one, he said, you're gonna look back on these episodes and they're gonna seem like, oh, wow, we were really young or really hadn't, you know, not to say that we, like he thought they were great, It was just he had been on enough shows to know that you'll look back and realize, like, oh, we were still finding it.
是的，布鲁斯对我说，因为他参加了很多长剧，他说，也许在第一季的一半之后，他说，你会回顾这些剧集，它们会看起来像，哦，哇，我们真的很年轻，或者真的没有，你知道，不是说我们，就像他认为它们很棒一样，只是他已经参加了足够多的节目，知道你会回首并意识到，就像，哦，我们仍然在寻找它。
I think there's some truth to that, but mostly what I've been delighted by is we came out of the gate really strong.
我认为这有一定道理，但最令我高兴的是我们走出大门时非常强大。
Like, I think we did find the funny a little bit more, but that's natural because you introduced more things.
就像，我认为我们确实发现了更多有趣的地方，但这是很自然的，因为你引入了更多的东西。
Like, you didn't, we didn't know, for instance, that Robin was a gun nut.
就像，你不知道，我们不知道，例如，罗宾是个枪迷。
You know, that, like, hilarity for years.
你知道，多年来一直很热闹。
We didn't even know she was from Canada in the first episode, right?
我们在第一集中甚至不知道她来自加拿大，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
So, I think we maybe, maybe, maybe we did.
所以，我想我们也许，也许，也许我们做到了。
Oh, maybe we did.
哦，也许我们做到了。
Once, and they, but not, not extensively, we certainly didn't know.
曾经，他们，但不是，不是广泛，我们当然不知道。
We didn't know you as a writer's room, we're gonna declare war on Canada.
我们不知道你是作家室，我们要向加拿大宣战。
Ha ha ha ha.
哈哈哈哈。
But there was something about those early episodes, and the first two seasons where I was like, oh my God, there's so many like classic, great episodes in the first two seasons.
但关于那些早期的剧集，以及前两季，我就想，天哪，前两季中有很多经典、精彩的剧集。
Like, we really came out of the gate strong, and I was delighted to feel that.
就像，我们真的坚强地走出了大门，我很高兴感受到这一点。
I didn't feel like, oh my God, these early episodes are hard to watch.
我不觉得，天啊，这些早期的剧集很难看。
Like I didn't feel that at all.
好像我根本没感觉到。
I didn't feel that at all either.
我也完全没有这种感觉。
And I think in season one, like we're finding all these fun new toys to play with of like, what is this show?
我认为在第一季中，就像我们找到了所有这些有趣的新玩具一样，这个节目是什么？
In season two, I feel like it's more character.
在第二季中，我觉得它更有个性。
Like we're getting to know these characters more.
就像我们越来越了解这些角色一样。
Like you can only do Robin used to be a teenage pop star in Canada in season two, right?
就像你只能在第二季中罗宾成为加拿大的青少年流行歌星一样，对吧？
You can only, that's not gonna be episode five of season one.
你只能，这不会是第一季的第五集。
So there's this feeling of it unfolding and expanding.
所以有一种它展开和扩展的感觉。
It's almost like when you're friends with someone like, There are certain stories about yourself, maybe even this is true with a therapist, where you're like, this is a season three reveal of myself, I'm not gonna, I have terrible boundaries if I'm gonna say this in the first conversation.
这几乎就像当你和这样的人成为朋友时，有一些关于你自己的故事，甚至对于治疗师来说也是如此，你会说，这是我自己的第三季揭露，我不会，如果我要在第一次谈话中说这些，我就有可怕的界限。
Or like the first day or whatever.
或者像第一天之类的。
There are things you reveal about yourself when it's time.
到了适当的时候，你就会透露一些关于你自己的事情。
And I feel like there's an arc for that in the writing where you're like, you can only reveal that Robin's dad wanted a boy, and he treated her like a boy.
我觉得在写作中有一个弧线，你就像，你只能透露罗宾的父亲想要一个男孩，他把她当作男孩对待。
Like that would be bonkers to reveal that in the first few episodes.
如果在前几集里揭露这一点那就太疯狂了。
It'd be like, you have no context for that.
就像，你没有这样的背景。
Yeah, we're not even really there yet.
是的，我们还没有真正做到这一点。
I mean, that's the thing.
我的意思是，就是这样。
It's such an, this whole series feels like an excavation.
就是这样，整个系列感觉就像是一次挖掘。
Like you're just deeper, deeper, deeper, deeper.
就像你越来越深，越来越深，越来越深，越来越深。
What are you finding, and some of that's finding out just being inspired to do that from you guys.
你们发现了什么，其中一些发现只是受到你们的启发而这样做。
We were talking about this recently with a guest we have that I won't say who it is yet, But just that idea of like, the things you guys are doing week to week give us ideas, right?
我们最近和一位客人谈论了这个问题，我还不会透露他是谁，但就是这样的想法，你们每周做的事情给了我们想法，对吗？
Like the chemistry you have, like we're getting ideas, it's such a wonderful symbiotic relationship between actors and writers.
就像你们之间的化学反应一样，就像我们得到想法一样，演员和作家之间存在着如此美妙的共生关系。
And it's this ecosystem where everything has a job in the ecosystem and everything feeds everything else.
在这个生态系统中，一切事物都在生态系统中发挥着作用，并且一切事物都为其他事物提供养分。
And like, we got so many ideas simply from things you were doing and energies you guys were bringing.
就像，我们从你们所做的事情和你们带来的能量中得到了很多想法。
And it led somewhere for the writing.
它为写作指明了方向。
It also must be very satisfying and imagining as a writer, Like if you create a movie and it's like 90 minutes, 120 minutes, you get in what you get in.
作为一名作家，它也必须非常令人满意和富有想象力，就像如果你创作一部电影，就像 90 分钟、120 分钟一样，你会得到你所得到的东西。
And then there's a famous story, I don't know if this is true again, I might be spreading misinformation.
还有一个著名的故事，我不知道这是否是真的，我可能在传播错误信息。
But I heard that Mike Judge was in the shower one day when he came up with the perfect third act for office space, the movie office space.
但我听说迈克·贾奇有一天在洗澡时想出了完美的办公空间第三幕，即电影办公空间。
But the movie had come out years ago, it was done.
但这部电影几年前就已经上映了，已经完成了。
He just thought, no, that's actually a better third act.
他只是想，不，这实际上是更好的第三幕。
Like I've solved the movie.
就像我已经解决了电影一样。
What the movie was done?
电影拍了什么？
You guys had a nine year thing where you're like season three, you're like, oh, you know, it'd be fun.
你们经历了九年的事情，就像第三季一样，你会说，哦，你知道，这会很有趣。
Like the river kept flowing.
就像河水一直流淌。
So you guys got to keep adjusting the flow of the river and where it was going, you know?
所以你们必须不断调整河流的流量和流向，知道吗？
That must have been very satisfying.
那一定是非常满足的。
It was the best.
这是最好的。
It's this journey that continued and this iterative kind of like finding new speeds journey.
正是这个旅程持续不断，这种迭代有点像寻找新速度的旅程。
and I don't, I'm hard pressed to think of too many other artistic experiences where you get the gift of specifically that.
我不知道，我很难想象有太多其他艺术经历可以让你获得特别的礼物。
Like sometimes I think of the really long-running movie series like, I sometimes find myself comparing certain things in how much mother to the like eight movies of Harry Potter or all the books of Harry Potter.
就像有时我会想到真正的长篇电影系列一样，我有时会发现自己将《多少母亲》中的某些内容与《哈利·波特》的八部电影或《哈利·波特》的所有书籍进行比较。
Like the way that things unfolded and you really had the time and space for like the collective Star Wars movies, it's rare, right?
就像事情展开的方式一样，你真的有时间和空间来观看集体星球大战电影，这很罕见，对吧？
You don't usually get that much time to keep digging and keep excavating and see how deep you can go in the archeological dig, essentially, and we really got to do that.
从本质上讲，你通常没有那么多时间继续挖掘并继续挖掘，看看你能在考古挖掘中走多深，而我们确实必须这样做。
That's great.
那太棒了。
I'll just, we're gonna make it the Fatima show because this person keeps on just saying, the way they phrased it here is, the unpeeling of all the layers of the characters as we learn more were earned and felt intentional.
我只是，我们要把它做成法蒂玛秀，因为这个人一直在说，他们在这里表达的方式是，随着我们了解到更多的东西是赢得的并且感觉是故意的，角色的所有层次都被剥开。
That's fantastic writing, not knowing where you're going and still killing it.
这是很棒的写作，不知道你要去哪里，但仍然杀戮它。
Speaking of killing it.
说到杀掉它。
That's really cool, but I would really give the cast a lot of credit there too, because I really think we were picking up on different energies between you guys and different, like, you would show aside of Ted, Josh, that we'd go, oh, we didn't even think of that.
这真的很酷，但我真的也会给演员们很大的信任，因为我真的认为我们在你们之间汲取了不同的能量，不同的，比如，你会表现出泰德、乔希，我们会去，哦，我们甚至没有想到这一点。
Like, the way Josh read that line, the way that his energy was in that scene with that person, I want to see more of that, let's go to his job more.
就像乔什读这句话的方式，他在与那个人的那个场景中的能量方式，我想看到更多，让我们更多地去做他的工作。
Let's see this, like, it was very collaborative in a very intuitive way.
让我们看看，这是一种非常直观的协作方式。
It wasn't like explicitly said, we weren't constantly coming to you and telling you that, Josh, but like it's the truth and the whole cast, like you guys were writing the show with us in a lot of ways.
这并不像明确所说的那样，我们并没有经常来找你并告诉你这一点，乔什，但就像这是事实和整个演员阵容一样，就像你们在很多方面与我们一起编写这个节目。
Right, but we had nothing before we had something.
是的，但是在我们拥有一些东西之前我们什么都没有。
Like you guys gave us enough that we could riff upon.
就像你们给了我们足够多的东西，让我们可以即兴发挥。
You know, it feels a little like you give us the melody line, but we're jazz musicians, so we kind of like mess with it a little bit or put our little stamp on it.
你知道，这感觉有点像你给我们旋律线，但我们是爵士音乐家，所以我们有点喜欢把它弄乱或者在上面打上我们的小印记。
That's a good comparison, I think that's it, right?
这是一个很好的比较，我想就是这样，对吧？
It's very, there's a jazz-like quality to like nine seasons of TV.
喜欢九季的电视节目有一种爵士乐般的品质。
and it kind of goes places and finds new speeds.
它会去某个地方并找到新的速度。
And if you're, if you have the right musicians, it's a beautiful thing.
如果你有合适的音乐家，那是一件很美好的事情。
Yeah.
是的。
So I'm gonna ask one more question, but before I do just some technical answers for folks, they're asking where they're gonna be able to hear these later on.
所以我要再问一个问题，但在我为人们提供一些技术答案之前，他们会问稍后可以在哪里听到这些信息。
And the answer is just if you subscribe to the show, if you follow this podcast, everywhere the podcasts are available, these will pop up in your podcast feed, sometimes on Mondays when the show usually comes.
答案是，如果您订阅该节目，如果您关注该播客，那么只要有播客，这些播客就会出现在您的播客提要中，有时是在该节目通常出现的星期一。
Sometimes there'll be bonus episodes a little later in the week.
有时本周晚些时候会有奖励剧集。
So if you do an Apple podcast or Spotify or Amazon, you can check it out there.
因此，如果您制作 Apple 播客、Spotify 或亚马逊播客，您可以在那里查看。
Also, we just want to, real quick, we open every single episode with a voice note or voice, what do you call them?
另外，我们只是想，很快，我们用语音注释或声音来打开每一集，你怎么称呼它们？
Voice mail?
语音邮件？
Voice note?
语音笔记？
Yeah, voice recording.
是的，录音。
from a fan.
来自一位粉丝。
And the basic prompt is, tell us what this show meant to you.
基本提示是，告诉我们这个节目对您意味着什么。
Tell us what the show continues to mean to you.
告诉我们这个节目对您来说仍然意味着什么。
Tell us an interesting thing about your life and how it intersects and interacted with how I met your mother.
告诉我们一件关于你生活的有趣的事情，以及它如何与我认识你母亲的过程相交叉和互动。
We play those at the beginning of the show.
我们在节目开始时播放这些内容。
It's a great way to open with the voice from a fan.
这是用粉丝的声音来开场的好方法。
And then at the end, we often read a letter from a fan.
最后，我们经常读到一封来自粉丝的来信。
So if you would like to contribute either a voice note or a letter, go to how we made your mother.com, h-w-m-y-m.com, go to up to contact and just follow the instructions from there, it should be pretty clear.
因此，如果您想提供语音留言或信件，请访问我们如何创建您的 mother.com，h-w-m-y-m.com，转到“向上联系”，然后按照那里的说明进行操作，这应该很清楚。
And, you know, such beautiful stories, I just wanna say that, like we're really honored.
而且，你知道，如此美丽的故事，我只是想说，就像我们真的很荣幸一样。
The people have really shared some heartfelt things from their life and funny stories and meaningful stories, so keep them coming, it's the best part.
人们确实分享了他们生活中的一些真挚的事情、有趣的故事和有意义的故事，所以让他们继续来，这是最好的部分。
And a lot of questions that people are asking now, do get answered to the podcast, where do the names sparly come from?
人们现在问的很多问题都在播客中得到了解答，这些名字从何而来？
That's, you're gonna find that out listening to the podcast.
也就是说，你会在听播客时发现这一点。
that the writer Greg Malins is on the show with us and we go very deep into that.
作家格雷格·马林斯（Greg Malins）和我们一起参加节目，我们对此进行了深入探讨。
What somewhat COVA pH has a very specific question.
COVA pH 值有一个非常具体的问题。
They want to ask about specific shots like from the other side of the bar that only happened in the first couple of seasons.
他们想询问一些具体的镜头，比如从酒吧另一边只发生在前几个赛季的镜头。
Do you remember those?
你还记得那些吗？
And the answer is yes.
答案是肯定的。
And we talk all about those.
我们谈论所有这些。
Putting in the fourth wall, is that what they mean?
放第四堵墙，是这个意思吗？
Yes, yeah.
是的，是的。
It was rare.
这很罕见。
We really, we didn't do it that often but it was cool when we did it.
我们真的，我们不经常这样做，但是当我们这样做的时候，感觉很酷。
I would say at least once a season that wall flew in though.
我想说的是，至少每个赛季都会有一次那堵墙飞进来。
Yeah, maybe even a couple of times and sometimes it had to fly in and I think other times Pam, our director would just go, yeah, we haven't done that in a while.
是的，甚至可能有几次，有时它必须飞进来，我想其他时候，帕姆，我们的主管就会说，是的，我们有一段时间没有这样做了。
Let's put that fourth wall up and just shoot a conversation.
让我们把第四堵墙竖起来，开始一段对话。
Like that had really struck me.
就像那件事真的让我印象深刻。
There was that scene in stuff maybe.
也许在东西里有那个场景。
It wasn't where Barney has kidnapped all of Ted's stuff.
巴尼并不是在这里绑架了泰德的所有东西。
I think so stuff, yes.
我想是这样的，是的。
Where like, Pam just staged it.
就像帕姆刚刚上演的那样。
So the two of them were at the bar and so the over from like Neil to Josh was like, We needed the fourth wall.
所以他们两个在酒吧，所以从尼尔到乔什的对话就像是，我们需要第四堵墙。
If you're gonna shoot like on Josh's face over Neil's shoulder the way they were at the bar, you had to put in that fourth wall.
如果你想像酒吧里那样越过尼尔的肩膀朝乔什的脸上射击，你就必须安装第四堵墙。
And I thought that was great.
我认为这很棒。
It was a great scene between the two of them.
两人之间的场面真是太棒了。
Barney dropped some real wisdom in that scene and it kind of affects the outcome of the episode.
巴尼在那个场景中留下了一些真正的智慧，这在某种程度上影响了这一集的结果。
It was an important scene.
这是一个重要的场景。
And she said, let's bother with the fourth wall on this one.
她说，让我们费心处理这面第四堵墙吧。
Let's put them somewhere different and the scene will pop a little more because it's an important scene.
让我们把它们放在不同的地方，场景会更流行一点，因为这是一个重要的场景。
Yeah.
是的。
And okay, so a great last question here and we can wrap it up today.
好吧，最后一个问题很重要，我们今天可以总结一下。
This is from b.jordan.garcea.
这是来自 b.jordan.garcea。
It says, a question, if you could boil the series down into one central question that was explored, what would it be and what was the impulse to explore that?
它说，一个问题，如果你可以将这个系列归结为一个被探索的中心问题，它会是什么以及探索这个问题的冲动是什么？
And maybe we could even, you could talk about the whole series or maybe just the first couple of seasons because that's kind of what we're up to.
也许我们甚至可以谈论整个系列，或者只是前几​​个赛季，因为这就是我们要做的。
I think it's, for me, it's our foxes trying to seduce humans into domesticating.
我认为，对我来说，这是我们的狐狸试图引诱人类驯化。
That's really what I was training about.
这确实是我训练的目的。
That's what this IG Live has been about.
这就是 IG Live 的意义所在。
What this series about.
这个系列讲的是什么。
Okay, the series, okay, I thought there's just this hour.
好吧，这个系列，好吧，我以为只有这个小时。
The series is about so many things, but I guess just to bring it back to Mr. Vanderbeek, I would say evolution.
这个系列涉及很多事情，但我想把它带回到范德贝克先生身上，我会说进化。
This shows about personal evolution and the letting go of your frozen idea.
这表明了个人的进化和放弃你冻结的想法。
Like you use the word frozen, Josh, don't get frozen.
就像你用“冻结”这个词一样，乔什，不要被冻结。
Your idea of what it's all going to be like, instead embracing the chaos and embracing the change and embracing it, it's not all going to go according to plan, but knowing that what gets you through all of the bumps and turbulence of that is love.
你对一切会是什么样子的想法，而不是拥抱混乱，拥抱变化，拥抱它，一切不会按计划进行，但要知道，让你度过所有坎坷和动荡的是爱。
Yeah, I would just add also learning to trust that the universe's plan is better than mine.
是的，我还要补充一点，要学会相信宇宙的计划比我的更好。
Yes, yes.
是的，是的。
Deeper and more complicated and better.
更深、更复杂、更好。
It's just, yeah, that's what's being embraced in that evolution.
只是，是的，这就是这场演变所拥抱的。
I think so.
我想是的。
All right, well, thank you all once again for joining us for our Instagram live.
好吧，再次感谢大家参加我们的 Instagram 直播。
We're going to do a couple more of these, watch out on Instagram, for uh find out when that will be and of course check out the show how we majormother.com available wherever you get your podcasts.
我们还会做更多这样的事情，请在 Instagram 上留意，因为呃，看看什么时候会发生，当然，请查看我们的 Majormother.com 节目，无论您在哪里获得播客，都可以使用。
Thanks everybody, thanks for joining us.
谢谢大家，感谢您加入我们。
How We Made Your Mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas and is presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并执行制作，由 Office Ladies Network 和 Odyssey 出品和发行。
This episode is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
本集还由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛担任执行制作。
The show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
该节目由我 Alec Lev 制作和编辑，我们的联合制作人是 Doug Matica。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves。
Our digital content producer, aka Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumberg.
我们的数字内容制作人，又名 Z 世代大师，是 Emily Blumberg。
Artwork by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help the show.
对节目确实有帮助。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《New York City》，其他音乐由 Craig Thomas 和 Andrew Majuski 创作。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢洛拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Visit HowWeMajorMother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
请访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 了解更多信息，然后单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's newsletters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at joshradner.com.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Radner 的时事通讯，并在 joshradner.com 上查看他的音乐和其他所有内容。
Order Craig Thomas's debut novel, That's Not How It Happened, Wherever Books Are Sold, and check out his other published writings at CraigThomasRider.com.
订购 Craig Thomas 的处女作《That's Not How It Happened》、Wherever Books Are Sold，并在 CraigThomasRider.com 上查看他出版的其他作品。
And you can subscribe to my own Dead Father's Society, also on Substack.
你也可以在 Substack 上订阅我自己的《亡父协会》。
To learn more about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital pediatric heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解有关如何做出改变的更多信息，这显示了正在进行的为先天性儿科心脏病研究筹集资金的活动，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”选项卡。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞。
The real question, it just hit me, or just New York City.
真正的问题，它刚刚击中了我，或者只是纽约市。